[Music]
visited the Mary Kay headquarters with
the camera crew in the hopes of
realizing my dream here's what happened
well this is exciting I'm at the Mary
Kay headquarters in Dallas Texas and I
am sitting here with independent beauty
consultant Krystal hi Krystal hi how are
you very nice to meet you to meet you
and what's happening here we just got
engaged when did you get a gig last
Wednesday you got engaged last Wednesday
yeah I was told you were single what are
we gonna start with would we use my skin
ever yes well rape my skin you'd be and
be honest don't worry about hurting my
feelings what am I reading it on I don't
know yeah yeah one being it's horrible
ten being it's amazing yeah it's a five
I think you're gonna really love firm
foaming cleanser why is it called volume
firm what's that your skin does it firm
up everything I might need a lot of this
what's in this stuff let me see what it
says right here Agent Orange
that's this cornhusks huh baby teeth
okay fantastic one of the cool things
too for consultants especially new
consultants is we have all these books
and so for instance if the client has a
question I can say oh you want to know
about advanced age fighting power for
volume firm yes and I can say 86% had a
decrease in the appearance of average
wrinkle lance right Wow
77% found that it extended their life by
over fifty years
98% said that they had died but this
brought them back to life and made them
are you're sure these are real should I
be concerned the freckles are coming off
why would it be great
I like freckles you just said it would
be great if they cream on one of them
aha why would you assume I want them off
part of what our product does it helps
with aging I've had the freckles on my
wife I had the freckles when I was a
baby I said nothing about hitting my
freckles you're the one that said oh
good they're going okay I couldn't use
this obviously no man uses lipstick no
but you may want to try it because that
best way to become familiar with the
product is to try it that's plenty
not quite enough we've got a little
crooked we're everywhere oh yeah okay
yeah I see it now it's like that thing
we're in movies that cliche where a
woman goes insane you know and she's
like
[Applause]
I'll make them all pay you're not gonna
forget this prom
[Applause]
I forgot that as the chemical actually
need to go to the hospital a big
component of being with Mary Kay is
going to people's homes right where
they're having a party there's probably
a certain etiquette that's involved I'm
guessing yes we don't put it on them
they do it all by themselves so that
when they show them what is the rule the
rule is I'm not allowed to touch them
right Oh what can I interest you in
today all right I want the skin Vickery
brush this brush is fantastic
yes it exfoliates the skin I know I
can't touch you yeah
the police have asked me not to do that
you could do this to yourself good and I
can film it
[Applause]
now if I happen to see that in this case
that you're wearing an engagement ring
can I say oh my god watch this oh my god
girlfriend that ring
[Applause]
you what is this this is your beauty
coat this is gonna make you look really
professional WD coat yes can a man wear
this hello this is my friend crystal
we'd love to come into your home right
now if that's okay
I didn't bring a cell phone because
those could be traced later by the
police what do you mean no let's in the
door starts to close I put my foot in
let me in this feels like maternity wear
for ninja to sell cosmetics
[Applause]
I'm Conan how's everybody doing ladies
look lovely you look gorgeous in fact I
wouldn't change a thing I don't think
you need any cosmetics let's go no
pressure no pressure but I need to leave
this house with $25,000 this is the Mary
Kay skin vigor 8 brush I invite you to
place a little bit of the cleanser on
your hand do I'm not allowed let them do
it I've been told not to touch you I've
been told it's not that kind of party
if any of you should decide you want it
to become that kind of party I'm open
for business that's all I'm saying
brush can be yours for $50 however
because I'm here you can have this for
the absurd price of $9.99 I will pay the
rest if anyone wants to hug me after
that they're welcome to yes
[Music]
[Applause]
directly to the bronzer you can put it
on your cheek yes and then the forehead
you you help me out
oh yeah okay I get the cheekbones this
area this is I looked okay how about
like here thing in the shadows yeah
come to the party what I would suggest
is really take it on
[Laughter]
I feel outside and I peek in through the
window looking like this
very much and if you like what you see
right here then you'll like Mary Kay
[Laughter]
[Applause]